my wife said she hooked up with a dude
years and years ago and she goes down
she goes she goes to take his pants off
yeah and he had a micro penis and she
she was like like most people you're
like it's unicorn you're like is it real
yeah because I've never known anybody
you feel like you would need somebody at
some point don't you love it when your
wife makes up those yeah
you're a hook up with other guys one
micropenis at once
she's got a wife it was like she was
like I felt so bad yeah because it was
like she was like I there's not I played
with it for a second but there's nothing
you could do what do you did she rub it
like a [ __ ] yeah you do two fingers on
two or three fingers on no but she said
she said this she knew she this must
happen constantly every time that like
girls back off a little bit or they just
want to go kiss again or something and
then he you know pushed her away and was
like it's all right don't worry about it
this story come up were you talking
about like the biggest puss that you
ever done well yeah I talked about
walking into some
time to open it up
I think one time we were doing that
thing everybody's done that with your
significant other or your wife or your
girlfriend over at some point you're
like you know I want to hear I want to
hear some of the history for fun
give me a couple I want to figure it out
yeah because I want to know how do you
bring it up you're at dinner did you
like who have you had you had have you
what have you straight outside have you
had [ __ ] something else have you ever
licked a chick have you ever [ __ ] you
know what I mean like the girl stuff
[Music]
your wife didn't [ __ ] anybody before you
comedians or secure people
he doesn't mind his wife getting stuff
no I know everybody everyone no one
wants to know but you know it's a
reality yeah I just want to [ __ ] it I
want I wanted to hear we were sharing at
the beginning when we were first dating
I wanted I was like you know what's your
history like you know the number
imagine girl with triple digit body it's
out there dude oh dude it just has to be
out there yeah what do you mean it's
probably out there way more than you
know yeah
yes dude yeah yeah yes dude way more
than you think uh when a girl says like
10 she means 30 pill you think they
divided by three oh it's 100 American
emotions they divide their number by
three yes of course really
applying his number by three yeah yes no
American Pie two check it out I don't
know that was that was a great I I
believe that wholeheartedly yeah I think
they cut it in half and half yeah I
don't want to believe it guys multiply
that makes sense sorry man whatever
makes you sleep at night yo do you think
you think that your girl has slept with
three times the amount of guys she's
told you
you want to hear about a couple of the
previously
I just want to make sure you got good
taste yeah and make sure she got good
taste imagine all the dudes previous
were just some lame ass dudes and I'm
like [ __ ] am I one of those yeah come on
that's fragile yeah you can't even hear
that might be more fragile I don't know
that's weird
I hooked up with three girls yeah you
don't believe in yourself enough I'm
multiplying okay whatever we're all
multiplying a little okay it's
multiplied by one it's still one so you
don't think your girl has got the risk
unless she's hooked up with finer dudes
than you not finer but you want to know
that she's cut that she's interested in
good stock yeah